It's about time I calmed down. I
had planned to do this from the beginning. So when I met him, I was surprised. No, he was surprisingly okay. I didn't care. I
thought he would be more disturbed, but there are
other people who are investigating.  I'm here, but I'll meet you. It's okay.
After all, you've
become stronger.
Masamune worked
hard and was
able to lose weight and change. It's
okay now. Be
confident and
tell me to stop. Don't cry from my side.
[Music]
Thank you,
Aki.  Chan
[Music]
This isn't me, but it's White Day.
What's really in the white
chocolate? I'm sorry I don't have a game,
but it
tastes better than gay, right?
[Music] I want to touch it,
maybe I can touch it
[Music]
But
I'm sorry, I can't
accept this after all.
No. I think it's okay for at least one person to pick up something you'd like to throw away.
Goodbye, Makabe, Masamune-
kun.